and the pattern of the Target that maps
for data exploration by lalang lennis
it's a senior researcher at Tata
Institute for mathematics and Computing
he works to develop open source tools
for data science including
umap for Dimension reduction hdb scan
for clustering and tired and and decent
for approximately so this will help him
performance
thank you
[Applause]
yes it's okay
thank you very much thanks Vincent the
introduction
uh I'm going to be talking about data
maps for data exploration
this is Joint work with a bunch of my
colleagues at the top Institute John
Healy Hamlin and before I start I just
want to explain this is framing for a
big picture of you so I'm going to sort
of provide big outlines for a 50 000
foot view of how I wanted to do things
in more keeps your interest on getting
you some examples but I'm not going to
get into details of all the nitty-gritty
things
but first I want to carefully delineate
three different modes of doing data
analysis that I'm going to refer to as
query search and Explorer and each mode
is going to have an important place in
data analysis but some modes are
currently far better served than others
so to explain the multiply analogy I
want to I want you to imagine you've
just arrived at a vast Library you don't
know anything about
if you know exactly what you're looking
for which book you want you can just go
and ask the librarian and if they have
it they'll give you that book so this is
the query mode where you know what
you're looking for if you query for it
exactly
but sometimes what doesn't always know
exactly if you know the subject area
generally
and if you have a good librarian you can
go and ask that librarian and I'll
direct you to the right set of shelves
and you can browse through the small set
of books that are on those shelves and
find the kind of thing you want this is
what I'm going to refer to as search as
opposed to query you know querying a
specific thing you're you're searching
generally for the right section or right
areas to look
the last case is sometimes you don't
really know what you're even looking for
you just want to explore the library and
find what's in it
there could be all kinds of interesting
things you didn't know you were looking
for before you started and the way you
want to do that you just want to explore
the library ideally with a map of
section of labels so you can figure out
where to go to find the things that are
in there because you don't even know
what the library has
all right so let's talk about going from
a query based mode to a search based
mode
so this is the transition that is
already underway in industry and in
Practical terms working with data sets
is going to change from a query based
mode to more of a search based mode when
we're dealing with more and more of this
unstructured data so
here's some pseudo SQL that might be
querying you might have you want to find
movies like Casablanca
and the catch with this query mode is
you have to know a lot of specifics you
have to know the internal structure of
the database what the fields are you
have to be able to pick everything out I
uh properly did you misspell any names
did you yes the term that the database
uses incorrectly did you include too
many conditions to get nothing back did
you include too few conditions and
return the entire data table did you
accidentally doing how to join them
in contrast what you'd like to be able
to do is just what Google does right
just search movies like Pennsylvania
this is this is what Google returns for
you and it's pretty good actually it's a
pretty reasonable selection so the
question is how does Google do things
like this and the answer is picture
databases it will sort of referred to as
semantic search or a neural search
engine there are a bunch of different
names for this but it's really all the
same thing
and this is the sort of thing that
Google uses for its recommendations like
this or image search or video search
lots of companies are doing this sort of
thing and in fact Victor databases are
all the rage right now here's a bunch of
different startups that I happen to have
run into that are offering Vector
database Solutions
so what is a vector database solution
well what makes up a vector database is
two things one turning your data into
vectors and two being able to search
through those vectors very very
efficiently
and behind that turning data into
Victor's well
if you look at hugging face or open AI
or Google or Facebook turn out all kinds
of uh huge neural network models that
turn all kinds of things into embedding
dangers there's so many different ways
to do this it doesn't really deserve to
be spoken to in even more detail for
fast connector search there are actually
a lot of different algorithms and
implementations that will search through
giant databases of vectors for the
nearest neighbors of a Victor very very
efficiently there's solutions from
Google from Facebook from Microsoft or
Spotify and even any others
okay
so what we have to imagine is if you
wanted to convert a whole bunch of
documents into vectors how would you do
it well you could start with word today
you can just average four digits for the
document accounts good enough for short
documents but you know you could use
Universal standings encoder or sentence
that would be even better probably if
you have a big pile of images you could
use an image based neural network that
gives them biddings there are many
choices you could use your favorite
resnet 50 might be good
if you have a mixture of documents and
images open AI clip actually embeds text
and images into the same space you can
work with mixtures of the two
and the short answer really is that in
this day and age if you're working with
positive documents images audio video
all type there's already a pre-trained
model that embeds this into a vector
space for you
and if you have more specific data well
you can always fine-tune those models or
if you have really specific data you can
even build your own models yourself
and it's almost certain that there's a
positive search technique that's going
to suit you in the background of that uh
screenshot is from Alien benchmarks
there are so many different approximate
nearest neighbor search implementations
out there that the plots just look crazy
now there's going to be something that
works for you so this is capital
and the reason for this is that this
technology Powers all kinds of different
things from semantic search to query
expansion to fuzzy matching reverse
image search recognition systems anomaly
detection deduplication this combination
of powerful Victory representations and
fast picture search is rapidly becoming
foundational for particular a
foundational technology for all sorts of
data work
and there's another interesting thing
that's a little more subtle uh for
Vector databases that I really like it
kind of acts like API and Casual
encapsulation for data you can package
up a complex data set using Vector
embeddings encoding your domain
knowledge into the notion of similarity
or distance between those vectors and
now anyone who wants to use your
database doesn't they need to know
anything about how the internals of your
database Works they just need to be able
to say I want to find things like this
and that's all and better yet if your
internal data changes where what you
would have been doing previously is
adding extra columns to your database
tables
people aren't going to know about that
it doesn't matter because you just
encode all that new extra data you have
into it you Vector representation
publish it and as far as the end users
using that data are concerned they're
just saying buy me things like this
nothing changes they automatically get
all the benefits of that external
without having to know anything about
the data so
the internal schemas the internal
details don't need to matter anymore
okay so hopefully I've convinced you
that the search mode powered by your
databases is both powerful and
fundamental
but now I want to convince you that
there's one more step that we'd like to
take
that can provide really powerful tools
for data analysis
and allow you to explore data in a much
richer way
so
it turns out that we're visual animals
and there's nothing like looking for
finding things and especially if you
want to find things you didn't even know
you were looking for a visual
representation is going to be the best
way to do it what we want is that big
picture 50 000 foot view of everything
so you can start from there and then
work your way down find the things that
are of interest to you
and our solution to that is interactive
data Max
what's that well a data map is really
just the application of a dimension
reduction technique taking a pile of
high dimensional vectors and reducing
them down to two or three dimensions so
they can be visualized and applied so
each point represents a vector from your
original data and you can see the
structure and engine relationships
between these data points and recent
advances in the last two decades or
something provided far more powerful
manifold learning techniques that can do
this and provide really rich
representations even into or 3D
the problem is what does it really mean
if you're a data analyst and you just
get a plot with all of the dots on it it
doesn't really help you understand your
data maybe you can see some into
relationships but you need more than
that
so
Google Maps is the gold standard for
making data accessible and easy to use
in math form
and so my claim is we need to learn some
lessons from Google Maps to make our
data Maps more meaningful for a user
so what we want is our datamax to be as
accessible and easy to use to
interactively explore as Google Maps is
so let's go back and learn our lessons
from Google Maps first of all there's
down on the bottom right corner there
that interesting little thing and that
allows you to choose a zoom level
and that matters a lot
because it means you can zoom all the
way out and get the big picture view of
countries and continents you can zoom in
and get state level information you can
zoom in further and see cities further
still you can get buildings streets and
the key here is that the level of detail
that you need
for your task at hand can vary and you
need to be able to smoothly move from
one to the next to find whatever is
going to suit your task
but let's take a moment and go back out
to that state city level view that we
had there's something else important
going on here and that's these labels
these provide you a way to orient
yourself of what's going on in this map
if we took those away
I think people might actually struggle
to guess where in the world we were
looking at but as soon as those labels
go there you know what you're looking at
you can Orient yourself you can figure
out where to go where you want to zoom
in on
so labels like that are going to be
extremely helpful Google also provides
proper interactions you can hover over
any interesting data points and just
show you information about that data
point so you can quickly scan over a
bunch of locations find what's
interesting and when you click on it it
brings up a much more detailed report so
you can look into the details on it
being able to easily access a lot more
detail really matters to the user
experience
and of course it's Google so you can
search
and with a textual search list the user
quickly find potential items of interest
but it's more than that by showing the
search on the map
they get to see clusters and outliers
either of which might be important for
what they're doing
at least well known but very useful
feature is layers so you could turn on
different layers in a Google map and add
extra data so here I turned on layers
for the relief math showing elevation
and bike parts so if I was trying to
bike around Seattle this is information
I really really want I like to be able
to layer that onto the Mac depending on
what kinds of information one needs
so we need to make datamax as navigable
and easy to use as this
so how do we build a rich interactive
data map that an analyst can explore
like a Google Maps view of their data
set
there's a pipeline that we need to
construct to really make this all work
now the first two portions of this
pipeline data to vectors and fast Vector
search that's really what Victor
databases are all about
turning those vectors into Maps there's
a bunch of medical learning techniques
we can do that reasonably the Mac
annotation is harder and the interactive
visualization
is largely something you usually just
have to build yourself from the ground
up which is fine but it's a lot of work
so uh before I go on I want to highlight
our contributions because appetite
Institute we've been working on a
variety of tools and projects that can
be pieced together into a coherent
approach to do various parts of this
whole tool chain and I should note all
of this is open source it's all on
GitHub it's all on pipei you can go and
grab any of it and work with
so vectorizers is our set of tools for
vectorizing data now now we're a small
Research Institute in Canada we aren't
going to compete with Facebook Google
and open AI
at training giant neural networks we
don't have the data sets or the compute
to manage to do that so we're actually
interested in how to visualize all sorts
of other kinds of data the small data
idiomatic corpuses we work with cyber
defense uh in Canada the Canadian
government so IPS traffic flows event
logs malware binaries being able to
victorize all kinds of different kinds
of data is what this sort of tooling
that fills around
uh we needed Fastback to search we built
our own methods for this that sold our
problems it works with a lot of
different distance functions and a lot
of flexibility for things that we need
in practice it turns out it's actually
very fast and competitive with the
solutions from Google Facebook and
Microsoft
um we also built the umet library for
manifold learning it's become one of the
go-to methods for this data map style
approach
on the right there there's a couple of
uh websites to actually make use of umap
embeddings for interactive use of either
textbooks academic textbooks or actually
just non-fiction books sorry fiction
books and you can explore those and it's
a really fun way to explore and look at
things
quite some time ago we built a fast
scalable version of https game
clustering and that algorithm has proved
to be a crucial part in providing those
textual annotation labels and at the
varying levels of detail we need for
these data
so in essence we're using hdb scan and
hierarchical clustering and
density-based clustering to find the
equivalent of the countries State cities
suburbs streets in their data Maps
starting from just the data
and lastly we're working on TNT which is
our effort to put together a library
design to make it easy for you to build
an interactive data map either in a
notebook or as a wave application
and this is the newest of air projects
that's developing very very rapidly but
it's really for basic use now and
hopefully we'd love to have you uh try
it out and see how it goes so I should
note it's built on top of the panel
library from Air content so it really
just provides a Bunches of panes and
widgets that are pre-built for the needs
of building interactive data map tools
and you can take that as a big bucket of
Lego and glue it together in whatever uh
construction you need
very quickly so our goal here is not to
provide some very polished final product
that is fixed in stone but rather a
whole bunch of tools that you can get an
80 solution for your very specific
problem put together very quick
all right so that was some of the
technology what can we actually build
with all of this
so I want to provide an example I picked
an example data set of the core 19 data
it is a collection of tens of thousands
in fact almost a million now uh research
papers that are related to covid-19 in
some way
it's a lot of material to sort through
there's a lot of documents how does one
explore a data set at Large
well fortunately for us the court 19
data set comes with its own Vector
representation of the papers that was
using a different deep learning based
approach that actually is specifically
designed for scientific documents it
cares about uh citation information and
so on this is great we're just going to
use that out of the box
and that means we can apply umat
directly to those uh embeddings of the
documents to get our basic Mac before
where we want to go
and then we can use TNT to explore the
results for the purposes of the
stimulant like I'm down sampling to 100
000 papers that's more than enough to
provide a vast Corpus to sift through
so TNT makes making an interactive map
straightforward this is
the minimum you would need to just get
going you handed the data map and in
this case I handed it some povertex data
as well
and what you get out is something like
this uh the large cluster at the bottom
left there is uh just short articles
reviews commentary and stuff like that
so let's just ignore that for a moment
there's some interesting structure going
on here in the in the menu cluster uh so
what's going on there well it's an
interactive map we can zoom in easily
uh and you can hover uh over the things
and get over text
and you see that well there's something
about surgery related things there maybe
okay we can inject more information into
this pretty easily
uh to get uh making that more
comprehensible
so TNT is designed to make all this
stuff pretty easy we want you to provide
as little information as possible and
then we're opinionated about the results
so that you get something that should
work reasonably well so we can specify
some labeling by the primary field of
researching the paper and I'm going to
do Marker size based on the citation
count so that list cited papers kind of
fade further into the background
what we get out is something looking a
bit like that
and that can tell us a lot at a high
level most of the papers are from field
medicine which is exactly what you'd
expect but there are some notable
exceptions and there's a surprisingly
diverse range of fields
if we look at that area that we zoomed
in on before we can zoom in on that
again and we see there's a bunch of
different fields there and several
clusters have incredibly distinct
primary Fields so the surgical cluster
as one might expect is all about
medicine but there's this cluster down
here that's all Computer Science and
Mathematics not necessarily what one
would have expected to look fine when we
were looking through covid-19 papers and
there's also this other cluster here
where the predominant field is probably
environmental science so right away just
from having this as an app to look
through we've already found interesting
things to explore further
stepping back from that there's a lot of
papers here that are a lot of separate
cluster have a surprisingly large range
of different fields of study so let's
zoom in there
um there aren't distinct clusters purely
in points but there's clusters in the
fields of study there's this group which
is largely papers from business and
economics and then another small group
here that's a different environmental
science cluster so there's something
interesting going on there
to make this easier to navigate and make
more sense of we can use a bunch of
tooling from Air victorizer's library to
actually generate a shared Word document
space with the Specter document
adjectives
uh we can then use HTTP scan and
Pioneers in to Cluster the papers and
find nearby words to those cluster
centers if you're familiar with the top
to back topic modeling algorithms is
basically doing exactly the same thing
and all of that work actually turns out
to be very easy in TNT we've automated
most of that away for you because this
is the sort of thing you're going to
want to be doing a lot and so this is
more of an eye chart I'm not expecting
you to read the code in detail or see
that it's still not a whole lot of code
and you can get a result more like this
where now we have high level labels that
we can look at help guide what we're
looking at
so let's zoom into that region again you
can see the surgery cluster gets
keywords like under millimeters ectomy
this is obviously surgery related
um and in the uh environmental science
cluster you've got Dash 95 that's
obviously from n95 worn and Airborne so
this is probably about masking or air
quality things like that
if we actually zoom in further more more
detailed labels reveal themselves and we
can see that computer science cluster is
actually about uh clearly deep learning
and if you Mouse over that that's all
about deep learning for chest x-rays uh
there's seir modeling and on right and
then there's a group with iot Bluetooth
and things that's from internet all
things and that's actually all about
Bluetooth uh and iot devices being used
for code tracking X so you can find all
the papers about that pretty quickly
that environmental silence cluster we
get more detailed labeling it makes it
clear what topics are covered there it's
all about airflow aerosols indoor
respirators masks all the things you
would expect to be in there somewhere
and obviously there are a whole bunch of
environmental sign-in papers about that
we can explore some of those other areas
of Interest
here we see some of the overlapping
layers of labeling with the economics
splitting out about concern about
markets in the face of covid and
managerial and organizational changes
that were brought by covid from remote
work policies we can also see those
papers clustering uh Stress and Anxiety
from the psychology field as well as a
cluster down on the bottom it's all
about education probably remote learning
zooming in further we can see further
delineations in the economics papers
and that uh that environmental science
cluster that we didn't really understand
has passenger transportation bus it's
obviously about all the changes uh to
things like air quality when there were
subtle drops in the amount of Travel and
Transport during covert
so with just a little work we have tools
that allow us to quickly and easily
navigate the vast and diverse Corpus
that we had there makes it easier to
find things of interest
but TNT allows us to add other ways to
interact with the data as well
so this time this is an eye chart I'm
not expecting you to read this I'm
putting this here so you can see this is
the total amount of code required it's
not a whole lot
and the thing here is that we're putting
in a whole bunch of different extra
building blocks that can add information
for being able to search
and information pains control pains to
layer different data over the over the
plot and lift them all together easily
so what we get is something a bit like
this you can serve it up as a way back
from the command line or you can view it
natively in a notebook it doesn't matter
this is one of the beauties of panel
that lets you do either or and if you
click on an individual Point it'll bring
up all the details about the paper
including a link to the actual paper
itself so you can go and read it
we also have a search pane you can
search for whatever you want just
strings in the in the data and you can
tie this search to whatever metadata you
want it doesn't need to be anything
specific it just needs to align uh Row
for row with the data that is being
plotted
so you can immediately see two clusters
related to vaccines one cluster is all
about vaccine hesitancy and the other
posterior is in the biology field and
that's obviously all about vaccine
development
uh we have hot controls you can change
what you're coloring by
let's color by influential citations and
see which things are more influential
you can change the hover text column to
the tldr in the paper and here instead
of titles or the papers quick summaries
into papers all these things are easy to
put together and Link together as you
need
and there's still a whole lot more
tooling available in TNT here's a
preview of some of the stuff that's
that's on the bleeding edge as well as a
bunch of upcoming features so
in this case I've got an updated uh
version of the core data set where I
eliminated anything with an abstract
that was too short and removed the
little citation accounts so we get a
slightly different map but it can and
not that we're actually serving this as
a way back fire panel so we can have
things uh like a data table that changes
if we select points it'll only show in
that data table the selected points of
the cluster or a region that you
selected so you can interactively pick
out regions in the plot and find out
more about it
uh no also that there's a new label
button uh in the bottom right uh and
that's a label editor we can actually
select points assign them a new tag or
label and it'll store that information
off you can save it back and label the
data yourself so you could actually use
TNT to quickly build a a labeling tool
if that's what you want to do
the options are pretty Unlimited
so we've actually got several different
ways you can do search you can do a
keyword-based search that actually can
handle longer text a lot more easily we
have semantic search using effectively
in Vector database backing at all
whatever you want to do
and that's all just built in it's just
throwing the line saying I want a
semantic Search widget here
um we're also busy building out a
variety of summarizing tools so if you
select data you can get a summary of The
Selection so no at the very bottom there
there's a
distinct cluster that's in blue that's
CS papers
what's that all about well if you select
just those we get a word cloud summary
it's all about the things you would
expect
um and you know we have a summary of the
value counts of the different fields in
that in that custom or that selection so
uh it's really easy to build your own
summarizers we are building up a set of
different ones things like feature
importance plots and anything you can
think of it's actually pretty easy to
make your own all you have to be able to
do is take an input of data and output
either a data frame or a plot or some
HTML whatever you need
and lastly we're actually looking at
using large language models to generate
labels of those clusters instead of
using those sort of keyword descriptions
which are indicative of what's going on
uh you can actually hand a lot of the
information to a large language model
and get really readable results so
rather than things relating to surgery
we get medical surgical procedures
um and much more detailed labeling
it adapts to different kinds of topics
very well and provides an efficient
overview of the content you get things
like air quality impacts of covid-19
lockdowns that's a much better
description of that region of the data
set
and it provides good specificity in when
you zoom in as well there's a lot of
detail in those specific labels
so to wrap up what do I want you to take
away from this talk
um I I want you to take away the victory
Innovations are the future and you
should probably get on board now and
we're going to end up with a lot of
vector databases scroll the way in
organizations all over the place in our
future
and interactive data maps are a great
way to be able to understand and explore
a vector database
in a holistic way
so I want you to think about this as
exploratory data analysis for Big
unstructured Data or exploratory data
analysis for the 21st century when we're
not dealing with nice simple tabular
data where we can do statistical
standard exploratory data analysis now
we've got big miss the unstructured data
how do we look at that how do we explore
that
finally uh TMT our library is a powerful
way to quickly put together an 80
solution with interactive Dynamics and
different tools that are accustomed to
your needs so we're not providing an
Indian solution we're providing you with
the tools you need to build whatever it
is you want to build
now all of us and more can be found on
GitHub we'd love to collaborate and
expand what these kinds of tools can do
so by all means come talk to us uh you
can find us on GitHub thank you
thank you
[Applause]
yes at the back yeah
um this is really cool
um at the higher level clustering label
is really interesting and I could see
how that works when we're dealing with
embeddings of text Data I'm wondering
does this work for situations where the
underlying things are making a betting
as far as not text and like we can maybe
make the entire
levels that a subject matter Africans
later come and label after the factor is
that is that part of the support so I
believe I'm sure I'm saying your
question it's that uh with tick state of
the high level labeling looks kind of
good yeah but can we handle other sorts
of data yeah and so the answer to that
is yes uh the labeling I showed there
was a
uh joint Vector space labeling technique
but we actually have a bunch of
different ways of generating labels
Based on tabular data we can do feature
important space labeling of clusters for
what makes this cluster distinct from
the others we can work with sparse data
we even got random sampling based
labelers uh we can label with uh this is
upcoming I've got prototypes to do it
label with images rather than text so if
you have a giant file of image data and
you want some labels you can have like
example images hovering over the
Clusters and they'll change as you zoom
in around so yes we can handle more than
just text and we would love to be able
to handle even more I think it's not so
bad to add even more different ways of
generating these sorts of labels so uh
if you have more ideas about what you
need please uh let's let's talk
yes uh thanks so much
questions
[Music]
you know for very large data sets uh
like Olin brown or how or where going
from 768
so uh the first question was about um
was that about scaling to really really
large deficits uh so uh the answer to
that uh I would check out the Rapids uh
Nvidia Rapids implementation or
umec which runs on gpus and that will
run very fast for very large data sets I
believe they have multi-gpu solutions
for that as well so you can even scale
it out to uh won't fit on a single gpu's
Ram so that would be a solution to that
the second question was about HTTP scan
for the clustering and it's
tricky sometimes to get parameters right
uh so we actually developed a slightly
different approach we're using HTTP scan
uh but
we've got some tricks uh built in here
to actually do the clustering a lot more
swiftly uh and avoid a lot of those
problems so really
um to build up the hierarchy it's a lot
Slicker uh than you might think and not
very hard to choose parameters uh
surprisingly well so we have solutions
for that problem we're we're very
familiar with the internals of age
keeping scans so we can mess with things
yes do you have any thoughts on if
you're working with data that doesn't
fall into completely into these
traditional categories how you would
generate that term settings for an EKG
data at the heart or something that's
kind of unbeatable
yeah okay so the question is how do you
generate Victor engines for things that
are more unusual data so your example
was EKG heart data
um
so
actually a sliding window I'm getting uh
based technique uh can work surprisingly
well depending on what you're trying to
get out of that data
the short answer is vectorizing data is
kind of down to what you're in task with
it is and I think that's a matter of all
you having the domain expertise about
that data
to work out the best way to turn it into
vectors our vectorizers package has a
wide range of different techniques for
working with variable length sequence
data is how I would describe it
um and it might have a solution that
might work for you
but in general that's a challenging
problem but I think it's a problem that
more and more people are going to try
and solve so hopefully either there's
already a solution for you but it's
probably one coming if your data is
popular enough
is that close enough to what you were
looking for
if it's not popular enough where would
you go hi so if it's not popular enough
I would I would look at our victorizer's
package because we actually really care
about data that's not having lots of
neural networks built for it we're not
building your early work techniques
we're building
a lot more just standard email
techniques for dealing with those sorts
of data and come talk to us we can try
and figure out if that is a solution for
you
and uh and think backing off of that
um what about uh what about language I
know language data is uh language is
really popular it has been processing
but
um what we do uh but this has this has
to do more with uh transfer learning
embeddings for transfer learning versus
uh test specific ones like would you uh
would you say the transfer learning
embeddings uh are tend to be really huge
because you're trying to throw
everything out of the kitchen sink or
um
and that's why
I I'm not quite yet like
our embeddings would you say that
embeddings for transfer learning type
tasks are going to be are going to be
bigger
isn't more prevalent yeah yeah I I
expect they'll get used because even if
they're not ideal they're probably good
enough for a number of tasks and being
good enough might be sufficient having a
fine-tuned model that's more specific to
your needs not necessarily for um
not uh not necessarily in terms of
problems but
um in terms of in terms of
because I want to be able to uh make the
make the embeddings uh compressible if
that makes sense or kind of make them
efficient face efficient
uh you you mean the dimension of the
ability
uh okay so the question is uh are the
are the transfer learning techniques
gonna produce higher dimensional
limitings generally yes
um quite possibly and certainly
the more that people are putting effort
into these various neural invading
techniques uh everything seems to be
getting higher and higher dimensional on
the other hand the popular manifold
learning algorithms tsuna umap things
like that actually do a surprisingly
good job working with even though it's
very high dimensional data sets and
still presenting a lot of really
relevant structure in 2D or 3D
representation so
um you still end up with good looking
Maps out of it
all right all right I'm keeping everyone
for lunch so thank you very much
[Music]
thank you